l'endroit est presque méconnaissable une
dizaine de tentes abritent 40 lits
d'autres l'équipement médical
le tout témoigne de la virulence avec
laquelle la maladie a frappé
l'arrondissement lasalle d'une douzaine
de résidences du sus du territoire
figurent sur la liste de surveillance du
ministère de la santé et des services
sociaux notamment le ch et celle des
floralies la salle pour lequel la
dirigeante du sus nous a dévoilé qu'elle
réclame la présence de l'armée
nous sommes en discussion avec le
ministère si une première priorité pour
faire entrer l'art mais ces floralies la
salle parce qu'en plus des 94 résidents
infecter un nombre important d'envoyer a
également contracté lakovic 19 ce qui
entraînait un appel à tous dans
plusieurs hôpitaux montréalais
on a des gestionnaires et des médecins
de 5 mairie et de la salle et des
élections qui se déploie pour aller
travailler là on comprend aussi pourquoi
la croix rouge a été appelé en renfort
pour installer en une dizaine de jours
un hôpital mobile à proximité de
l'hôpital lasalle lesieu s'attend à un
débordement de patients dans ce fait à
temps à n'avoir plus que nos capacités à
l'hôpital lasalle pour admettre des
patients zone rouge c'est une première
historique c'est la première fois que la
croix-rouge déploie son hôpital au
québec car d'habitude ce genre
d'installation la croix rouge s'en sert
dans les zones de guerre ou de
catastrophe naturelle la situation est à
ce point urgente que l'organisme
s'active aussi depuis une semaine à
former des équipes de nouveaux
travailleurs pour le sus de l'ouest de
l'île de montréal
est ce que vous auriez souhaité après
avoir vu ce que vous avez vu être
impliqué plus tôt la croix rouge
intervient lorsqu'on lui demande
d'intervenir
que ce soit le pavillon la salle où les
fleurs allié alors tout aux institutions
sur le territoire où il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de 2,2 zone rouge
alors on va on va sentir ici enfin comme
un soulagement à pois emploi en ayant la
possibilité d'accueillir ces nouvelles
personnes selon nos informations la
direction du ch et celle des floralies
la salle éprouvent de la difficulté à
avoir des horaires stable le recrutement
est difficile certaines des nouvelles
recrues ne terminent pas leur quart de
travail 25 employés sont encore en
quarantaine
et si maxime bertrand radio canada
morrell